was the Trump campaign it was comprised
of private citizens surveilled by the
Obama administration was information
collected and then retained about them
these are questions that should frighten
every American no matter what your
political affiliation was the government
spying on its citizens well we know for
certain that Carter Page who was on this
program earlier this week was targeted
and surveilled by the FBI he was
approached by an FBI informant who was
reportedly sent out to make contact with
Paige and other Trump campaign aides the
big question is did President Obama or
high-ranking White House officials know
of an authorized spying on a political
opponent mainly Trump and his campaign
staff well this is certainly not the
first time the government has surveilled
citizens or captured information on them
I want to take you back to a hearing
from 2013 when Senator Ron Wyden posed
this question to then Director of
National Intelligence James clapper what
I wanted to see is if you could give me
a yes or no answer to the question does
the NSA collect any type of data at all
on millions or hundreds of millions of
Americans no sir it does not not
wittingly yesterday clapper appeared on
the view where he tried to defend
himself against Trump's charges that
he's basically just a liar the
president's calling me a lying machine
well okay that stems from is an exchange
I had with Senator Wyden five years ago
in March of 2013 about a surveillance
program and he was asking me about one
and I was thinking about another so I
made a mistake but I didn't lie so
that's what occasioned uh yeah okay the
line well even Megan McCain could see
through clappers obfuscation what you're
referencing though is that when you said
when you're talking about James Snowden
blowing the whistle on the NSA illegally
spying
and in 2013 when you were asked about it
you said no so that that is a lie and
I'm sorry I was thinking about something
else what the heck was he thinking about
it's a lie and it is amazing to me that
clabber continues to go on national TV
again and shamelessly with a straight
face denies what we already know to be
true information leaked by Edward
Snowden national security contractor
completely contradicts clappers claims
the question from Wyden was simple and
clear and why himself is called out
clapper for all this repeatedly but I
think the most damning moment of clapper
is view of parents was this one was the
FBI spying on Trump's campaign no they
were not they were spying on a term I
don't particularly like but on what the
Russians were doing trying to understand
were the Russians infiltrating trying to
gain access trying to gain leverage does
this spying like I can't wait a sec if
he doesn't like the term he's the man
who oversaw massive surveillance and
intelligent eyes he is a problem with
the term spying are you kidding me but
the laughing really makes it very
believable none of this was lost on the
president who today tweeted Spygate
could be one of the biggest political
scandals in history then he doubled down
I mean if you look at clapper he sort of
admitted that they had spies in the
campaign yesterday inadvertently but I
hope it's not true but it looks like it
is we now call it spy game you're
calling it spy game a lot of bad things
have happened well bad things mr.
president have been happening for some
time now remember when clapper and Sally
Yates were confronted by Senator Chuck
Grassley about the unmasking of trump
officials they were surveilled remember
at Trump Tower mr. clapper initiates did
either of you ever requests the
unmasking of mr. Trump his associates or
any member of Congress
yes in one case I did it either of you
ever reviewed classified documents in
which mr. Trump his associates or
members of Congress had been on masked
oh yes you have can you give us details
here and there's no I can't
Mich aides have you yes I have and no I
can't give you details there is a little
doubt in my mind that we've witnessed an
outrageous abuse of our Intel and
law-enforcement agencies not because
Brennan or Comey or clapper we're
convinced that Russia was rigging the
election but because they wanted to
hobble a much bigger threat Donald Trump
the Obama crowd was so brazen and so
confident that they were doing the right
thing I think in the end they were
actually really sloppy at least seven
trumpets Oh shi'ites are suspected of
being surveilled Steve Bannon Michael
Cohen Lieutenant General Michael Flynn
son-in-law Jared Kushner Paul Manafort
Carter Paige and George papadopolis we
also know that at least four top Obama
officials regularly requested that the
names of Americans be unmasked for
Samantha power this was reportedly a
near-daily undertaking during the 2016
campaign that year 2016 now here's why
all this deep state intrigue matters the
Obama team had a material interest in
spiking the Hillary Clinton email probe
in making way for the Trump Russia
investigation their careers and their
legacies hung in the balance as Andy
McCarthy of National Review rightly
points out in a column today had Hillary
won the election many of these officials
would have retained their jobs
and would have been able to cover
whatever schemes they ran during the
Obama tenure they simply could not
permit Trump to take the presidency and
once he was within striking distance I
think they got really desperate
desperate to wrap up that Hillary probe
so maybe she could you know
take the white house like they always
thought and desperate to collect dirt on
Trump to destroy any chance of that
candidacy it is a rich irony that the
very people who claim that they wanted
to stop Russian interference in our
elections adopted the tactics of a
totalitarian state like Russia to stifle
political opponents and to subvert the
election of Donald Trump given all of
that it made me howl when Chuck Schumer
said this yesterday president's behavior
is the kind of grossly autocratic
behavior we'd expect in a banana
republic not a mature democracy a place
where citizens particularly political
opponents are spied upon falsely charged
and unjustly imprisoned what Trump is
attempting to do is to expose the
corruption in our Intel and law
enforcement services which Congress and
the President must exercise exercise
their oversight over in the wake of 9/11
conservatives were willing to trade our
privacy for security we're now being
photographed by the government how many
times a day can't even count our money
and our persons are tracked at home and
abroad well we the people and our
elected officials should not be
endlessly trailed and treated like
dangers to the state and we certainly
should not be spied upon for political
reasons the ever-expanding surveillance
state is a threat to our freedom and
some within these agencies think they
are omnipotent and above the law they
are not this is a president who will not
be controlled and who will not be
manipulated and he's insisting on full
transparency that's a novel concept that
the deep state better get used to and
that's the angle